Here's the answer to turn this parser from a slow one to a fast one
that doesn't repeat its work.
All we need are these five characters.
All we have to do is say let's apply the memo decorator to parse_atom, and then we're done.
The recursive call to parse_atom with term and the remainder as inputs.
We've done it once. This'll be the same call here.
We just look it up in the cache table, and we've got the result.
Notice in order to make that work, I had to make this function, parse_atom,
be something that had arguments that were hashable.
The atom and the text are both strings and those are both hashable,
but the original call to parse that had a grammar as the third argument--
well, the grammar is a dictionary, and dictionaries are mutable, so they're not hashable.
I couldn't memoize the the whole parse function, and then have parse be called recursively here.
That's why I had to have parse_atom and parse_sequence
be internal functions inside the definition of parse,
so that the grammar would be a variable that this function knows about,
but it's not one of the arguments so that the memo decorator works.